what's going on guys this is rob and dr
strange's what if episode episode number
four i'm pretty sure just gave us the
major or a major plot point for
spider-man no way home
and here's how so what happens over the
course of this episode okay the gist of
this what if episode is that instead of
stephen strange breaking his hands on a
car wreck what if his girlfriend
christine dies this leads to him being
guilt-ridden and ultimately trying to
find a way to bring christine back he
comes across the ancient one the ancient
one trains him to become the sorcerer
supreme and a lot of the stuff pretty
much transpires the way that you think
it would he ends up fighting dormammu he
defeats dormammu so on and so forth the
big difference here and where everything
shifts is that because of the fact that
the death of christine still weighs on
his mind he ultimately ends up using the
eye of agamotto which as we know houses
the time stone to go back in time and
find a way to save the life of christine
the problem is everything he does fails
no matter the circumstance she always
ends up dying sometimes she gets shot
sometimes the building catches on fire
and blows up regardless of the situation
christine will always die the ancient
one reappears and then tells steven
strange her death is an absolute point
in the timeline now that harkens back to
the events of loki when owen wilson's
character told loki that there are fixed
points in the universe things that
cannot be changed they have to happen a
really good example of this is when the
judge told loki that the avengers going
back in time during the events of
avengers in-game had to happen right
because thanos blinked out half the life
in the universe they couldn't go back
and stop thanos from performing the snap
because the very fact that they had to
go back in time to stop thanos indicates
this snap had to happen otherwise you
would create a paradox so to avoid that
they went back in time grabbed the
infinity stones brought them to the
modern day and then undid the snap that
way now the question is why was
christine's death an absolute point in
the timeline because the death of
christine is what led to steven strange
becoming the sorcerer supreme in the
first place and gaining the ability to
go back in time and stop her death it's
what you call a grandfather paradox
right if you gain the ability to time
travel you went into the past and you
killed your grandfather
then how could you exist to go back into
the past and kill your grandfather you
create a paradox now in marvel comics
they answer that and they solve that by
just creating a branch universe and
that's kind of what happened here that
when stephen strange indicated to the
ancient one that he didn't care about
any effects it would have on the
timeline and that his only real concern
was amassing enough power to save
christine's life the ancient one split
the timeline and so what you got was
timeline 8.1 and timeline 8.2 and in 8.1
steven strange never went back in time
to save the life of christine right in
that moment when he was talking to wong
and he was obsessed with the idea of
saving her life he put down the eye of
agamotto and said no we don't need to
worry about that timeline 8.2 is the
timeline we've been talking about where
he did go back into the past and all
that kind of stuff so you can call 8.2
doctor strange like sad sad strange
right you can call him sad strange and
then 8.1 you can call him happy strange
and we'll just use those two names for
the rest of this video now over the
course of this whole thing sad strange
ends up basically just kind of bringing
forward all these demonic entities and
then absorbing their power right in
order to make himself stronger and happy
strange is just kind of continuing on in
his role as a source for supreme but
neither one is aware that the other
exists right they don't even know
there's like a separate timeline within
the same universe they don't know that
that's not supposed to happen right
universes are supposed to have a
singular timeline and that's it right
just from the past to the present done
right just one whole timeline like what
basically happened here was the ancient
one like taking a road that was designed
for one vehicle and then splitting that
road in half and creating two lanes of
traffic right that dog don't bark it
just don't work it's not supposed to
happen that way and so because steven
strange sad steven strange kept doing
all his stuff he was basically
destabilizing the universe at the same
time ultimately of course he ends up
basically saving christine's life after
absorbing happy stephen strange and then
basically dooms all of reality in the
first place right so quite literally
what sad strange had done was knocked
out the wrong jenga piece at the wrong
time and the whole universe came
crashing down that's basically what took
place in reality he seems to have been
the only survivor of that universe which
has happened multiple times in marvel
comics hyperion kevin beshear the son of
blue marvel the fury like galactus when
he fought the watcher at the end of time
that kind of thing has happened multiple
times right being the last survivors of
a universe in fact we know that when
franklin richards the son of reed
richards when the universe ends he'll
actually merge with galactus and then be
reborn as an even more powerful being
and whatever universe comes next so it's
not uncommon to see that kind of thing
take place now here's how i think the
events of the what if episode tie into
spider-man no way home i think what's
going to happen in no way home is
exactly what happened here that
basically the timeline is going to be
split where the ancient one is the one
who split the timeline to basically
create a chance whereby sad strange
could be defeated by happy strange which
we know didn't work that it's gonna
happen accidentally in the events of no
way home that for whatever reason
probably due to the fact that peter
parker wouldn't shut the hell up dr
strange's spell went awry and when it
did it split the timeline by accident
that's what he's referring to when he's
saying that peter is living two separate
lives and the longer he does that the
more it deteriorates the timeline and
the universe how those timelines take
place we're not fully aware we could say
that in one of these timelines no one
knows that peter parker is spider-man
and the other one everybody knows and
that things just kind of pop off from
there we don't really know how somebody
like dr octopus appears in this or how
elektro or any of those other characters
presumably the lizard from all the
little clips and things that we've seen
we don't know exactly how all that's
going to unfold we can largely assume
they've been there the entire time truth
to tell because mysterio had been there
the whole time we just didn't know until
far from home that he was a guy who
actually worked for tony stark and it's
just kind of been [ __ ] over constantly
so it wasn't until they were kind of
like yeah he was always there that it
turned out he was always there right so
it's very easy to do with somebody like
dr octopus or the lizard or something
like that and the reason why is because
in all honesty it's kind of ridiculous
for us to believe that we're aware or
spider-man is aware of every single
villain that exists in new york that
doesn't really seem to be the case now
again how all that ties in together i'm
not entirely sure which is why i'm not
saying that dr strange the what if
episode gives us the entire plot for
spider-man no way home but i think it
gives us a big plot point what i think
is going to happen is it's going to
create different timelines in the same
universe that's going to destabilize
everything and in the end it's all going
to have to come to a head why does that
matter because i imagine it could be one
of these things like what they did with
age of apocalypse back in the 90s in
marvel comics when that alternate
reality was collapsing and people
escaped into the main marvel universe
like dark beast an evil version of hank
mccoy which was kind of weird holocaust
yes i know
not the best name for marvel to have
chosen for a villain that was literally
radioactive
and killed people
would you choose that name marvel but
nonetheless just different things like
that they escaped that timeline and so
this is one of those things where you've
got alfred molina's doctor octopus
you've got willem dafoe's green goblin
you've got jamie foxx's electro you've
got like the lizard maybe possibly i'm
not really 100 sure it's entirely
possible like when the movie ends and
this timeline collapses right it all
kind of gets condensed back down into a
singular timeline because the day saved
or whatever some of those guys make it
some of those guys actually make it into
the universe and now they're there
inside the marvel cinematic universe
right fighting off against spider-man or
whatever the case happens to be i don't
know i have no real idea here none of us
know until we either see more trailers
or until we actually see the movie but
with that being said guys i love this
episode of what if it was absolutely
phenomenal right it was a beautiful
episode you know i'm as as melancholy as
it sounds
i'm kind of glad it ended on a dark note
right one of the things that really
always kind of bothered me with comics
especially with marvel comics in terms
of losing the real world element is that
things largely seem to end on a happy
ending right for the most part right
like we literally just finished a story
where a guy from the multiverse who
created the symbiotes was trying to
destroy everything and eddie brock quite
literally venom by himself saves the day
as cool as it is
sometimes i just kind of like to see
stuff fail right i know it makes me
sound terrible i promise i'm not a
terrible person but i know it makes me
sound evil
like i'd love to watch people fail like
that's not really what i what i mean
here you know failure like i'm not
shooting for that i'm just saying it
makes things a little more tangible and
it actually gives real gravitas to what
we're seeing and at the end of the day
the watcher was right messing with
timelines screwing up this whole
multiversal universal pattern stuff like
that will lead to death and destruction
and it was an absolute revelation when
it came to steven strange sure he saved
the life of christine doomed the entire
universe in the process and she ended up
dying anyway right and so all there is
left and really all that is left is just
him and this little tiny space and this
great big huge empty void that was the
universe because given how it ended i
assumed he survived so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end and thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace